PROMISE CALL PAU MORE LAWYER
>> WELCOME BACK TO LAS VEGAS.
NOW TIS THE SEASON OF GIVING
AND SUBARU OF LAS VEGAS, THE
SPONSORS OF THIS SEGMENT,
THEY'RE RE'RADY 'RTO MAKE A
STOPPED BY TO SHARE THE LOVEE .
IT IS THAT TIME OF YEAR YOU
SEE THE CHRISTMAS TREES ARE UP
HERE A SUBARU AND WE'RE READY
TO SHARE THE LEAD GREAT
BRITAIN, WE ARE ALREADY SET
AND GO I TOLD YOU THIS IS MY
FIRST CHRISTMAS TREE OF THE
SEASON HERE IT'S TIME TELL US
MORE ABOUT SUBARU SHARE THE
LOVE OF IT AND WHAT WE'RE WELL
WE LOOK FORWARD TO THIS EVERY
YEAR THIS IS OUR 15TH YEAR OF
THE SEA WE SHARE THE LOVE
EVENT AND IT REALLY IS A
CELEBRATION OF ALL OF THE YOU
KNOW THEY ARE DOING SUCH GREAT
WORK AND OF COURSE WE SUPPORT
THERE IS FOR NATIONAL
CHARITIES THAT SUBARU IS
SELECTED.
>> SPCA THE MAKE-A-WISH MEALS
ON WHEELS AMERICA.
>> AND THE NATIONAL PARK
FOUNDATION. SO THOSE ARE
NATIONAL CHARITIES HERE THAT
ARE GOING TO BE RECIPIENTS OF
THIS GREAT EVENT WE ALSO HAVE
A COUPLE HOMETOWN CHARITIES
THAT WE'RE VERY PROUD PRESENT
A CHECK TO LATER ON WHEN WE
WHEN COLLECT ALL THE MONEY
THAT IS THERE GOING TO BE THE
RED ROCK SEARCH AND RESCUE SC
WHICH IS A GREAT ORGANIZATION
AND ALSO THE JUST ONE NOW WHY
THESE CHARITIES TELL YOU RED
ROCK SEARCH AND RESCUE IS OUR
LEGACY CHARITY. WHEN WE WERE
ABLE TO ADD ADA HOMETOWN TYRANN
I THINK IT WAS BACKED IN 2012
SO 10 YEARS S S S S AGS O S WE
THEM BECAUSE THEY REALLY DO A
GREAT WORK ALL VOLUNTEER,
FIRST RESPONDERS I'M RETIRED
MILITARY PEOPLE THAT REALLY
CARE ABOUT THE COMMUNITY AND
IN A SPECIAL WAY. AND WE KNEW
THAT WE COULD MAKE A
DIFFERENCE IN HELPING FUND
THEIR WORK NOT ONLY LOOKING
FOR PEOPLE OUT THERE IN THE
MOUNTAINS IN RED ROCK IN THE
CANYONS A STEP BUT ALSO HERE
IN TOWN YOU KNOW PEOPLE THAT
ARE LOST TO ALZHEIMER'S
PATIENTS CHILDREN, IT'S A
GREAT WORK AND AND THEN WE
HAVE A ROTATING SECOND CHARITY
AND THIS IS THE SECOND YEAR
THAT WE HAVE ACTUALLY SELECTED
TH
E JUST STSTSTSTONE PROJECT THEY
POP-UP GIVE COMMUTE TO MARKETS
AND THEY HAVE SUCH GREAT
RESOURCES THAT YOU KNOW THAT
THEY ENGAGE WITH THE LOCAL
COMMUNITY TO HELP  MEET THOSE
NEEDS NOT BEEN HERE WHEN YOU
PRESENTED CHECKS TO BOTH OF
THOSE ORGANIZATIONS AND THEY
ARE JUST SO GRATEFUL. YOU DO
THIS EVERY YEAR YOU KNOW WHAT
DOES IT MEAN TO MAKE THAT KIND
OF IMPACT.
>> IT'S POWERFUL, I YOU KNOW
IT TRULY IS MORE BLESSED TO
GIVE THAN TO RECEIVE AND.
>> THIS THE NATIONAL. OUT
THERE IS GOING TO BE GIVEN
WILL I THINK WILL TOTAL
250 MILLION OVER THE COURSE OF
THE SUPER SHARE THE LOVE EVENT
AND LOCALLY WE'VE BEEN ABLE TO
DONATE OVER THE 15 YEARS ABOUT
$300,000 SO THE AMOUNTS THAT
WE'RE GOING TO BE ABLE TO
BLESS THE SECURITIES IS
SIZABLE AND SO WE'RE REALLY
EXCITED ABOUT THAT AND THE ON
CHARITY OF COURSE WAS ABOUT
CARS TO YOU KNOW WHAT'S NEW IN
THAT DEPARTMENT. WELL WE
FINALLY HAVE CARS IN STOCK 3
MEDIA DELIVERY, YOU KNOW FOR
THE LASTE  YEAR AND A HALF YOU
HAD TO ORDER A NEW THROUGH IN
IN ORDER TO TAKE ONE.
>> OUT THE DOOR.
>> AND BUT NOW WE FINALLY HAVE
SOME ON GROUND INVENTORY TO
CHOOSE FROM  YOU CAN STILL
ORDER A CAR IF YOU WANT TO BUT
YOU KNOW IT'S JUST A GREAT
TIME RATES ARE STILL REALLY
GOOD. I MEAN WE HAVE RACE AS
LOW AS 3.9% FINANCING FOR UP
TO 48 MONTHS ON APPROVED YOU
KNOW FOR WHAT QUALIFIED BUYERS
AND SO D D D D D ITD 'S D STILL
TO BUY AND WHAT BETTER TIME
THAN THE
>> GETTING THIS IN THE SPIRIT.
THANK YOU TO FINLEY SUBARU OF
LAS VEGAS RESPONSE DURING THAT
SEGMENT
STOP BY ON ROY HORN
WAY OR CALL